all right let's bring out beast mode he
is the entrepreneur behind beast mobile
and beast mode who in his spare time is
an all-pro Oakland Raiders running back
please welcome Marshawn Lynch
[Applause]
[Music]
John Lynch is here alright so so glad
you're here it's that football time of
year only three games left the
conference championships are Sunday my
birthday and it's gonna be great thank
you
and then the Super Bowl so somebody on
my staff said you know we have a
football player on and I said well we
don't really do that on this show but if
you want to do that get me the most
interesting one and that's why you're
here because I know you don't give
interviews a lot but you have a lot to
say right well I feel like the Dos Equis
man up here the most interesting man
well I hope you are so how much longer
are you gonna play because it's a
dangerous game and you're a very bright
guy you don't want to you know every
football player they study the brains
when they after they die and you know
there's this not good things going on in
the brain do you worry about that
I do I mean that's why I hit everybody
with my heat you hit them with your hair
I do it's got to be the first thing to
go don't know I think that's where this
conversation is now I got but it's been
my best weapon and it's led me to I know
but let's it's not the future are you
gonna play next year I mean if if it
works out that way then I will that
sounds like Trump we'll see what happens
so let me been in the news a lot you
know Tom balls you have yes I know I
mean do you talk to Colin Kaepernick um
we share takes messages okay so just as
a fan besides what I think is wrong with
that politically that he's not playing
you know football is really only a good
game when you have an elite quarterback
would you agree with that I'm do yeah
okay you can't really come back from if
you're behind without a great
quarterback it's just an interesting for
the fast so is your taking a shot at no
no no no I I mean
what I meant to say is running back
that's what you need a great running
back but no you need a great quarterback
and the fact that no one will give him a
job is just disgusting yeah I mean it's
a it's real interesting just just saying
the type of should there be going on
with this kind of situations but at the
same time I mean you look at a lot of a
lot of guys that has been in the lead
that don't get to come back from some
other type of situations that's not as
serious as here's like you know got a
couple guys we get suspended for
marijuana and you know they don't get
the opportunity to come back you ever
tried it have I ever tried it once or
twice in my life you living your life
I'm 34 34 thank you very much
yeah okay so but when you were caught up
in that I mean Trump tweeted about you
he said that you were better pretty much
unpatriotic because you were taking a
knee what is your answer to that I mean
it [ __ ] say a lot of [ __ ]
and call me unpatriotic but I mean you
know you come to you come to my
neighborhood where I'm from me you know
you'll see me take the shirt off my back
and give it to someone and less need I
mean what would you call that no I know
you do a lot for your neighborhood you
wanted to play in Oakland again to be an
example for the kids to see someone who
could rise that far up and and you do a
lot against gentrification what tell us
what that is first of all for people who
don't know what that means
well I mean especially when for me slaw
white people come moving to the hood and
kick everybody out that's their that's
what it is yes
I mean that's that's the main [ __ ]
basically that's how it go I mean and
I've been I've been the witness over
since uh you know I was a small
jitterbug so I mean now that I'm you
know I'm growing up and now I'm saying
and I understand it a little more but
what do you do to combat that well now I
mean you know I got it to do with
banging my head against people I had the
opportunity to make it help with Eilis
right so therefore I started to going uh
you know buy up some some real estate
and I know the area where I grew up at
in order to give people opportunity you
know for housing and you're a man of the
people but I understand
when people want a picture you only take
pictures with women and children I would
rather it that way
we'd all rather it that way but it looks
bad we're not trying to force it that
way you try to force it that way enforce
it they're low enforce it yeah with your
head now with my feet I'm just no I just
I just mostly dudes are gonna be your
fans they're football yeah so that's
where I expect it to be yet but I mean
you know if you get to the point where
you know you got a lot of things going
on like I think it's called like cloud
chasing there's something like that it's
a new time that you know the people
that's under 32 are using right now and
34
you